Look.
You clicked on this video.
You knew what was coming.
Let's get this over with.
Naked Gardening Day is in May, and World Naked
Bike Riding are coming in June, and nude and
underwear runs happen all over the world,
but all this naked celebration got me pondering
the intersection of nudity, health and science.
Being naked helps us form a realistic body
positive connection to the human form.
People who spend time naked have a better
body image, don't objectify as quickly, and
are more confident and cozy in our skin!
But outside of bonus of a realistic self-image;
there ARE concrete, scientifically proven
benefits to being naked!
Firstly, being naked exposes more of your
skin to the sunlight, which means more Vitamin
D exposure -- which is great -- and it helps
your bones absorb calcium, so being naked
will help you get strong bones.
But you also have to look out for UV radiation,
so remember sunscreen.
A study from the University of Reading claims
if naked, we would have fewer parasites living
on our bodies overall.
Humans are petri dishes as it is, we're constantly
covered in bacteria -- some good some bad.
Clothing, like fur, promotes increased bacterial
load by giving it a comfy dark place to gather
and spread.
Since the invention of clothing, scientists
can point to specific evolution of lice and
other human skin parasites,; though, unlike
fur we can swap our outfit when it gets too
germy.
But, by comparison, research looked at the
bacterial load on naked molerats and other
hairless non-aquatic species and found lower-than
expected levels!
So being naked, would likely decrease bacterial
load on the skin for humans too!
Sleeping nude has been shown to have myriad
of scientific benefits.
When the human body settles into the sleep
cycle, our temperature drops; which is why
it's better to sleep in a room that's less
than 70 degrees [21C].
Research in the journal Sleep found sleeping
with clothes on prevents this natural cooling
cycle.
That cooling triggers the release of human
growth hormone from the brain, restoring skin
and regenerating the body -- that regeneration
requires energy, which your body gets from
fat -- which burns when we cool off during
sleep.
Get naked, and you'll sleep BETTER because
the body won't be fighting to control your
temperature.
Plus, you decrease stress hormones like cortisol
because you'll sleep better overall.
Sleeping naked with a partner has some obvious
bonuses… wink wink; but less-than-obvious
is simple skin-to-skin contact during sleep.
When skin touches during sleep -- even in
a non-sexual way -- the hormone oxytocin is
released lowering blood pressure, decreasing
inflammation and lowering stress hormones.
A study in Japan found sleeping with a bra
or girdle constricts the anatomy and can raise
body temperature and decrease melatonin.
So, sleep naked at least, but that's easy!
The rest of the day is a challenge, but there
are benefits there too.
For instance, though this doesn’t exactly
make the case for total nudity, research shows
that neckties can be harmful to your health.
A study in the British Journal of Ophthalmology
asked men to wear and tighten a necktie, while
doctors monitored their intraocular pressure
-- a moderately tight tie caused physical
changes to the eyeball which upped a risk
factor for the development of glaucoma!
So do ditch the tie.
And while you're at it, ditch the tight pants
too.
The science is iffy, but some doctors claim
tight pants for men can inhibit sperm development,
and tight clothing for women allow for bacteria
to cultivate in the vulva and within the vagina.
Hair or fur exists to keep animals warm, AND
to protect them from the sun.
We don't have the fur, likely because we have
one of the best sweat systems around!
Sweatier humans needed less body covering,
because it interfered with the evaporation
of that moisture.
Clothing, like artificial fur, interferes
with sweating… so in case you didn't get
the moral of this little story…
GET NAKED MORE.
Do you like being naked?
Or are you a never-nude?
When i get home, the first thing I do is take
my pants off.
Seriously.
Tell us how you feel in the comments.
And while we’re talking about skin, have
you ever wondered how your skin is being affected
by the sun?
You can find out in this video